a new twist in the hostile takeover of
Venezuela's opposition controlled
Parliament nearly two weeks ago soldiers
prevented opposition leader Huang hua
from entering the legislature while a
small group of dissident deputies
installed their own man as Speaker of
the House with the government's full
support now the majority opposition
leadership is showing what it says is
proof of how the government tried to buy
off deputies to oust why though
including Alfonzo Medina the thing is we
agreed on $700 initially there was
another proposition of 1 million I
suggested 1.2 but they came back with
500 and said no that's unacceptable so
we arrived at middle ground of 700,000
which is still money you know Martina
says he met and taped Jose Noriega a
deputy who'd been expelled from his
opposition party offering him the bribe
just ahead of the January 5th vote for
control of Parliament he says only 16
out of more than 100 deputies took the
bait and that he and others who refused
are now in danger today I am being
seriously threatened in my physical
integrity and that of my family al
Jazeera tried without success to speak
to Noriega who nevertheless responded to
the accusations on Twitter calling the
recording a hoax and threatening to take
his accusers to court for slander he
added if deputy Martina had this audio
why didn't he make it public two weeks
ago after the election of the director
of the National Assembly he didn't
because he didn't have what is a vulgar
montage we asked Martina the very same
question and he responded that it was
because of fears for his and other
deputies safety now that they've gone
public he says that if anything happens
to them they were hold President Nicolas
Maduro personally responsible the White
House has accused the Venezuelan
government of using bribery tactics to
oust what it regards as the legitimate
opposition leadership and slap sanctions
on deputy Noriega
according to The Voice transcript the
so-called turncoat deputies met with
President Maduro personally the night
before the bribe offer was made to
calculate how many votes were needed
none of this is admissible in a court of
law
but then it's the court of public
opinion that the opposition is trying to
win over to see inhuman al Jazeera
Caracas